thank you prime minister you talked in
your speech about a moral duty
to unite and level up our country but
over the past month
you and your ministers have stoked
division
over football has taken the knee saying
it was gesture
politics saying it was fans choice to
boo
the team and going back there is further
evidence of this divisive politics and
language from you be it
describing with muslim women as
in veils as letter boxes or bank robbers
or indeed african people as pick a
nannies with watermelon smiles
for many people your own record
personally undermines your image as a
unifying prime minister
what are you going to do to change that
well
thanks beth obviously i uh you know i
reject that
um uh disagree with it i should say and
i think that racism has absolutely no
place in our society
and i think that the england team
represented the very best of us
and our country and i think that the
overwhelming support the
the outpouring of love for the england
team after the match on sunday showed
this country at its best and
at its most united and i think what we
all want to do is
uh take practical steps to prevent
racism
uh in all its forms and i think the
football banning order regime the
changes to that
that we've announced will be valuable
you can't go to the match if you're
guilty of
uh promoting uh hate and racism
online but we've got to go further we're
going to use the
online harms bill to ensure that the the
big internet
uh companies the uh the social media
platforms
uh that allow uh race hate
uh to be peddled on there on their
platforms can face
fines amounting to ten percent of their
of their global revenues
uh and we and i as i said to them the
other day uh when i got them that got
them all in i had facebook and twitter
and snapchat and
instagram i can't remember the other
ones uh those are the main ones
uh you know i i said we will not
hesitate to go further
because uh they ca they do have the
technology
to sort this out they can adjust their
algorithms and we will
use legislation if we have to just as as
we
use the threat of legislation for
instance to stop the uh the european
super league
thanks very much beth can we go to alex
forsyth of the bbc
you said you rejected what i said but it
is true that your ministers did not from
the start
condemn the booing of the players do you
think that was a mistake
and as pm do you personally now regret
not being strong enough about this from
the right from the start
i always said that it was wrong to
taboo uh the england players beth and
that is my firm
belief and i think that as a society
what we need to do
is understand that we've made progress
in tackling racism i would say in my
lifetime
a lot of progress but i think we have to
recognize
that there's still a long way to go and
we've got as a government uh to lead and
to to use the the tools we have at our
disposal
the ones that i've i've just mentioned
to show that we are firm
and that there are things we simply
won't tolerate and to take the argument
and the fight
uh to those who control these these very
powerful
uh media uh platform social media
platforms
with their immense ability to to wound
and to undermine they can stop it and
we're going to make sure
that they do thanks very much beth